G
DELAYED, 120 PAGE JOINT W.H.O.
CHINESE REPORT INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE CORONAVIRUS HAS LANDED
WITH A BIT OF A THUD.
MORE THAN A DOZEN COUNTRIES,
INCLUDING THE U.S., UK, CANADA,
JAPAN, AUSTRALIA, ISSUED A
JOINT STATEMENT RAISING CONCERN
ABOUT THE CREDIBILITY AND
INDEPENDENCE.
THE REPORT DOES NOT INCLUDE A
DEFINITIVE CONCLUSION ABOUT
WHERE THE VIRUS CAME FROM.
IT SAYS IT WAS MOST LIKELY IT
JUMPED FROM AN ANIMAL, PROBABLY
BACK TO HUMAN.
THE DIRECTOR GENERAL OF THE
W.H.O. SAYS HE DOES NOT AGREE
WITH THE FINDING THAT THE VIRUS,
WHICH LEAKED FROM A LAB ORATORY,
WAS RESEARCHED EXTENSIVELY
ENOUGH.
HE SAYS FURTHER STUDY IS
NEEDED.
PART OF THE W.H.O. TEAM WHO
TRAVELED TO CHINA IS HERE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> GOOD MORNING, FOR ME,
ANYWAYS.
>> THERE SEEMS TO BE AGREEMENT
AMONG MANY COUNTRIES THAT THE
W.H.O., IN MANY WAYS, WAS HAD.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THE
SENIOR WHITE HOUSE ADVISER,
ANDY SLAVITT, ON TUESDAY.
HERE HE HAS.
>> WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
METHODOLOGY OF THE REPORT
BETTER.
WHERE THE INVESTIGATORS WHO
WROTE THE REPORT GIVEN COMPLETE
ACCESS?
WERE THEY IN ANY WAY INFLUENCED
BY THE GOVERNMENT IN CHINA WHEN
THEY WROTE THIS REPORT?
UNTIL WE KNOW THE ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS, I THINK IT'S
BEST THAT WE VIEW THE REPORT
WITH HEALTHY SKEPTICISM.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS ANDY SLAVITT
JUST POSED?
>> I THINK SKEPTICISM AND HIS
OPINION WAS ALREADY CIRCULATING
BEFORE THE REPORT EVER CAME
OUT.
IT'S A CONCERN FROM A GROUP
THAT FEELS THE VIRUS CAME FROM
A LAB HAND THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
WHAT WE DID WITH OUR CHINESE
COLLEAGUES TO COLLECT, DISCUSS,
AGGREGATE, ANALYZE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT'S AVAILABLE
BASED ON A LONG LIST OF STUDIES
THAT WERE DONE, AND THAT'S NOT
AN INSPECTION.
THAT'S NOT AN AUDIT.
IT'S A JOINT STUDY.
I THINK THERE IS
MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW THIS
WAS SET UP.
DID WE DISCUSS THE POSSIBILITY
OF A LABORATORY LEAK?
YES, WE DID, WITH ALL THE LABS
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN THE EARLY
RESPONSE.
WE VISITED THEM AND DISCUSS THE
SECURITY AND THE PROGRAMS OF
WORK, THE TRAINING OF THE STAFF,
THE TESTING OF THE STAFF, AND
WE DID NOT FIND ANY INDICATION
OR NEED FOR FURTHER FOLLOW-UP.
WHAT WE DO SAY, OF COURSE, IS
IF THERE ARE THESE ACCUSATIONS,
IT WOULD BE GOOD IF THERE IS
REAL EVIDENCE TO SHARE WITH THE
W.H.O..
>> ON THE ISSUE OF THE STAFF AT
THE LAB IN WUHAN, THROUGHOUT
NOT JUST THIS PARTICULAR GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, BUT FOR GENERATIONS,
DECADES, CHINA HAS A HISTORY OF
COVERING UP, LYING, OBFUSCATING,
AND BEING LESS THAN TRANSPARENT
AND NOT TELLING THE TRUTH.
WHY WERE THEY GIVEN THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT ON THE SITUATION
IN THE LAB?
WHY ARE WE TAKING THEM AT THEIR
WORD?
>> WE WERE DISCUSSING ALL OF
THIS, AND LIKE WE DO WITH
SCIENTIFIC COLLEAGUES, THIS IS
HOW WE APPROACHED THIS WITH
JOINT STUDIES AMONG SCIENTISTS.
WE SCRUTINIZE THEM AND THEN SAY
THE CONCLUSIONS.
IF YOU SAY, BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU, THEN THAT ENDS ALL
DISCUSSION.
AGAIN, THAT'S NOT HOW THIS WAS
STAFFED.
YOU NEED AN INSPECTION OR
SOMETHING.
>> WHAT IN THIS REPORT CAN YOU
POINT TO AS SOME KIND OF NEW
PIECE OF EVIDENCE, NEW
REVELATION, SOME KIND OF
BREAKTHROUGH IN THIS
INVESTIGATION?
WHAT DID YOU ACTUALLY GET BY
GOING THERE TO CHINA THAT WAS
WORTH RISKING THE CREDIBILITY
OF THE W.H.O.?
THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
WHAT WAS THE RESULT THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE?
>> WHAT WE GOT, FOR PEOPLE THAT
READ THE REPORT, THEY WILL SEE
8 SEPARATE STUDIES WITH
EXTENSIVE NEW DATA COLLECTION
ON SURVEILLANCE DATA, MAKING
MORTALITY, AND ANALYSIS GOING
BACK TO SEPTEMBER TO WUHAN IN
HUBEI PROVINCE, EXTENSIVE
TESTING OF ANIMALS AND ANALYSIS,
WHICH COMBINED, GIVES A MUCH
DEEPER, BETTER VIEW OF WHERE
THE PANDEMIC REALLY STARTED, IN
WUHAN.
THROUGH DECEMBER, THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE FOR EARLIER CASES, AT
LEAST NOT WIDESPREAD.
BUT THERE WERE CLEAR LEADS TO
THE NEXT STEPS.
>> TO BOIL THAT DOWN, YOU ARE
SAYING WHAT WE DID LEARN IS
THAT WE CAN DEFINITIVELY SAY
THIS BEGAN IN DECEMBER AND NOT
BEFORE?
>> NOT WIDESPREAD.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND A
SMALL CLUSTER, WHICH IS THE
NEXT STEP, AND WE DISCUSSED
WITH SMALL BANKS IN HUBEI AND
THEY HAVE SAMPLES STORED THAT
WILL NOW BE AVAILABLE FOR
FURTHER STUDIES.
>> WHAT'S THE REASON?
>> YOU REALLY NEED THE FIRST
POSSIBLE CASES FOR INTERVIEWS
TO GET CLUES ON THE REALLY,
EARLIEST STEPS.
>> QUICKLY, WAS THAT
INFORMATION WORTH THE BATTERING
TO ITS REPUTATION THE W.H.O. IS
NOW TAKING?
>> THE BATTERING IS NOT FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
IT'S SOMEWHAT SELECTIVE --
>> CERTAIN COUNTRIES?
>> THE EU HAS ISSUED A VERY
DIFFERENT STATEMENT.
YES, I DO THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE LEARN FROM THESE THINGS.
EMERGENCIES CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE
AND IT'S GOOD TO DIG DO